jetzt kommt im moment trommelwirbel ist
klassischer fall für trommeln würde
sie werden sie erreichten aber riesig
großen also unfall aber groß also ja
also der koloss von rhodos vergrößern
so jetzt streiten beide die werden
wahrscheinlich noch eingewiesen wie man
richtig anschaulich aber trommelwirbel
so die regie hat jetzt hoffentlich etwas
vorbereitet an trommel und jeder hat
eine kordel an ich fasse es nicht es
wirklich ganz brüderlich geteilt wird
einen tick härter ziehen um zu zeigen
wer der boss ist lächeln beide schöne
schön miteinander umgehen war wirklich
spannend jetzt sehr weltlich gelöste
stimmung
sie scherzen miteinander also unser
minister die attacke habe
ja es ist die forschung man das paket
auch machen ist schnell aber etwas
anderes erwartet hatten ein kommt ist
das ein bisschen zu früh für eine
künstlerische urteil das das war bei
jedem kunstwerk so ist wird erst die
zeit zeigt ob es denn also mit abstand
mit zeitlichen abstand wird man
beurteilen können ob das eine gute seien
schlechte start ist aber es ist auf
jeden fall ist sie endlich zu sehen und
sie zeigt dana wie es ist von william
und harry offenbar gewünscht war
und du wirst du auch über die im laufe
der sendung immer wieder gesagt haben
dajana als hüterin und beschützerin der
armen schwachen und und der kinder und
der der entrechteten also das hat sowas
von madonna an robin hood das ist ja
auch ganz angemessen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren